It's been always 250 years since the United States of America was founded.
And in that time,
the bloody war that followed the writing of the declaration of independence has
been imbued with an almost mythical quality rather than a simple conflict over
taxation and the right of self-governance the American revolution has instead
become a morality tale,
the triumph of good over evil of freedom over tyranny.
The many played a part in the country's formation has become legendary figures.
None more so than George Washington. Everyone knows who George Washington is.
His face is on the $1 bill. The Capitol of the United States is named after him.
And the tallest structure in the Capitol is a monument that is dedicated to him.
He was the victorious general of the revolutionary war,
and then served as the first president of the United States.
His face and name are pretty much everywhere.
The Romans used to worship dead emperors as gods and the U S has come very close
to doing the same to George Washington,
but buried beneath the myth is the story of a real man,
a man who is full of contradictions,
Washington fought for the freedom of others.
Yet he himself owned hundreds of slaves.
He is known as a master military strategist.
Yet he made several major mistakes that almost cost the Americans.
The war here's called the father of the country.
Yet he has no children of his own. He wasn't perfect. He certainly wasn't a God.
But what he was was uniquely American
Washington was born on February the 22nd,
1732 in the English colony of Virginia.
The Washington family had immigrated to Virginia from England in the 1650s and
had become one of the wealthiest families in the colony.
They owned several tobacco plantations that were worked by hundreds of slaves
and the wealth,
this produced for them allowed them to become foremost among the new class of
American aristocrats, a status they'd been unable to achieve back in England.
Augustine Washington George's father was very active in local politics,
serving as a justice of the peace and County sheriff.
He died suddenly in 1743 when George was 11 years old and much of the
Washington's estate was handled by George's older brother Lawrence who George
idolized, Washington was considered well-educated for amount of his time.
He was trained as a land surveyor and showed talent as a mapmaker and a
draftsman.
But the teenager wasn't content with such a sedate profession and he craved
action and adventure. When George was 19,
his brother Lawrence became ill with tuberculosis.
The brothers traveled to Barbados hoping that the warm climate would alleviate
the condition, but Lawrence died in 1752 and George returns home.
Now the sign of the Washington family.
Yeah.
Virginia Washington,
sorta commission in the Virginia colonial militia being appointed as a major by
the new tenant governor of the colony.
It joins the military at a very dangerous time on the frontier to the West of
the established British colonies.
They are higher river Valley was being contested by both great Britain and
France.
Both of whom were building forts at strategic locations to solidify their hold
on the territory.
Washington was named deputy commander of the Virginia regimens that first
professional colonial military units,
the regiment was ordered to March to the forks of the Ohio,
the future site of the city of Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania,
to oppose the French movement there in 1754. On the way there,
the commander of the regiment, Joshua Fry fell off his horse and broke his neck.
He died soon thereafter and his commands, pastor Washington,
Washington arrives at the forks and discovered the French had gotten there first
and began construction of their own fortress,
forced decane Washington retreated to contemplate his next move. And,
and he was joined there by our friends who had made the year before the sacrum
of the Mingo tribe, Tana chairperson,
Tana chairperson informs him of a force of about 35 French soldiers approaching
their position and suggested an attack on may the 28th, 1754,
the two forces confronted each other what's happened is next is a master of
dispute. All that is known for sure is that by the end of the encounter,
most of the French detachment was dead, including its commander,
Joseph [inaudible].
The French would claim that Davinia was there on a peaceful diplomatic mission
was massacred. Well,
Washington believed that the French would that to spawn his forces,
whatever happens the battle of juvenile Glenn, as it later became known,
proved to be the spark that touched off a worldwide war between great Britain
and France known as the seven years' war.
After the violence that German Avila Glenn Washington figured that the French
Garrison at Fort Duquesne was going to attack him sooner or later.
So we built a Fort of his own called Fort necessity.
It was a crude construction, essentially, a wooden Palisade,
and it wouldn't hold off.
They determined to solve for long Louie [inaudible] outraged at his brother's
death led a force of 600 soldiers to Fort necessity and attacked it on July.
The third, the Virginians were on disciplines.
They fled on the fire is at one point during the day,
broke into the liquor cabinets and got drunk.
When the French offered to allow him to return to Virginia with his troops on
harms. If he surrendered the Fort to them, Washington,
that felt he had no choice and marched back to what he thought was disgrace and
the end of his military career to his surprise,
the Virginia House of Burgesses blames the Devita Fort necessity on other
factors and not on Washington. The next year,
the British center force of 2000 soldiers under the command of general Edward
Braddock to capture Fort Duquesne.
Washington came along as a guide because of his experience with this area,
the British met with disaster at the battle of Monongahela on July the ninth,
1755, two thirds of the British force was killed or wounded, including Braddock,
Washington,
and some distinction during the basle by forming a rear guard to prevent the
retreats from turning into a route resulting in even more casualties,
Washington would serve in the colonial militia until 1758.
When he resigned in disgust,
after being rebuffed in his attempts to secure a Royal commission and the
British regular army,
the British commanders dismissed Washington and other colonial leaders as
amateurs and simpletons and assessments that would come back to haunt them a bit
later.
In.
1759, Washington married Carter's so young,
wealthy widow with one of the largest plantations in Virginia,
when combined with Washington zone holdings,
he was now one of the richest men in the colonies.
He delighted in raising your stepchildren, Jack and Patsy casters.
Although he and Martha never had any children of their own,
despite being married for 40 years, it is believed that about with smallpox.
As a young man had rented him sterile Washington, entered politics,
serving in the house of Burgesses and entertaining.
People of rank it as a state Mount Vernon.
He grew increasingly concerned throughout the 1760s and early 1770s with the
British Parliament's attempts to exert more control over the American colonies
through taxes, Washington,
and many others felt that this was an act of tyranny since the Americans had no
representation in the government that was making the laws that they were subject
to in 1775, the increased tension.
It finally snapped into open conflict in Boston where British troops under
general Thomas gage were trying to subjugate and increasingly rebellious
colonial populous at Lexington and Concord on April the 19th,
British regulars and colonial militia sheltered each other for the first time,
formally beginning the American revolutionary war Washington represented
Virginia at the second continental Congress in Philadelphia,
which opens soon after the bloodshed in Massachusetts, on June the 14th, 1775,
the Congress created the continent's Alarmy to provide for the common defense of
the colonies and talk of who would command the new army.
Soon turn to Washington. Washington had never actively campaigned for the job,
but he was the only delegate who attended meetings of the Congress wearing a
military uniform, which is a perfect example of dressing for the job you want.
That's combined with his height. He was six foot two,
which was much taller than the other delegates,
as well as the fact that he was the most famous soldier in the colonies because
of his war service 20 years earlier,
made him the unanimous choice to lead the new army. On June the 19th,
he received his commission and three days later, he departed
When Washington arrived in Boston,
he found his army was really a ragtag group of militia units with no real
organization after the battles of Lexington and Concord,
and the British had retreated back into the city and as the Patriots,
as they began to call themselves at blocks off the land routes into the city and
to put it under siege,
Washington immediately began shaping the militia into a proper army while
keeping the British bottles up in Boston. In October King, George,
the third replaced general gauge with a new commander William Howe finally in
March of 1776,
the continental army placed cannons on the high grounds of Dorchester Heights
and the games bombard the British positions in Boston.
This compelled how to retreat to Halifax by sea.
And as the Americans had won their first victory, Washington,
wasn't about to rest on his laurels. However,
a few weeks later he moved his army South to New York city, Washington.
And how both knew that New York was key to controlling the continence and
Washington expected a British invasion force to attack that he spent the next
few months preparing fortifications and continuing to train his troops.
British ships began arriving in New York Harbor on the 2nd of July.
We're always boosted in the continental army a few days later,
word them of the ratification of the declaration of independence,
which stated that the colonies were declaring themselves free and independent
States on August the 22nd general,
how landed at Brooklyn on the Western end of long Island with 20,000 troops,
five days later, he attacked Washington's position.
The battle of long islands was a stinging American defeat.
The continental suffered 20% casualties.
The American revolution could have ended right there,
but Washington organized a stealthy nighttime retreat across the East river onto
Manhattan islands. When the British short, the next day,
they were astonished to find that the Americans were simply gone on September
the 15th. The British landed on Manhattan islands.
The American troops did not even attempt to stand and fight,
but fled in a panicked route. Washington was enraged. The cowardice of his men.
And at one point was within a hundred yards of the advancing British troops.
An aide had to grab the bridle of the General's horse and lead him away.
New York fell soon after runs would be occupied by the British for the remainder
of the war.
The continental army was pushed through New Jersey and into Pennsylvania.
When winter sat in and Halbrook off his pursuit in the 18th century,
armies typically did not fight in Windsor and how returned to New York.
So wait for the spring thought, Washington,
meanwhile knew that he had to do something.
Morale was at an all time low desertions were increasing in Washington figured
if he didn't attack to quickly, his entire army would dissolve.
Washington has developed an effective spy network by the end of 1776,
since he received intelligence that a Garrison of 1,500 German mercenaries has
scions where in winter quarters, near trends in New Jersey,
they were complacent and not expecting an attack.
That was where Washington planters strike.
He hopes a victory would boost Patriot morale and lead to a surge in volunteers
on Christmas night, Washington led his army on a stealthy,
nighttime crossing of the Delaware river into New Jersey,
remarkable military feat. On the morning of December the 26th,
the Continentals took the Haskins completely by surprise and took over 800 of
them prisoner.
They also took tons of crucial supplies and weapons to equip their army with a
few days later, the British attacks Washington's position at Trenton,
and we're a pulsed Ben in another remarkable military maneuver,
Washington circled around the British army and attack the Garrison at Princeton
inflicting the third defeat on the British in 10 days,
the British retreated from Southern New Jersey and Thailand Washington finally
went into winter quarters at Morristown.
This stunning series of victories likely saved Washington's army,
but the war was still far from over.
British.
For the war in 1777 was more complex than the year before an invasion army led
by general John Burgoyne called gentlemen,
Johnny for his elaborate uniforms and lavish lifestyle would advance South from
Quebec to take Albany New York. The goal was to isolate new England's,
which had the highest concentration of Patriots.
And it was contributing the bulk of volunteers to the continental army from the
rest of the colonies,
which they felt would be easier to control how in New York were supposed to send
troops to support Bitcoin,
but controversially failed to do so like D due to personal rivalries between the
senior British commanders. Instead in the summer of 1777,
how's it out from New York to capture Philadelphia where the continental
Congress met,
how defeated Washington at the battle of Brandywine in September and did
Philadelphia. The Congress fled West to York, Pennsylvania,
but the real action was taking place in the North. In New York. Gentlemen,
Johnny had led his men into a tramp without realizing it,
finding themselves completely surrounded by an American army commanded by her
ratio Gates. He expected help for help, never came.
And he was defeated in detail by the Americans in two battles at Saratoga in
September and October products over the 17th,
he was forced to surrender his army to Gates.
The surrender of Bitcoin sent shock waves around the world.
Nowhere more so than in Paris, since the war began,
the French government had been looking for a reason to support the American
cause since it would hurt their British rivals,
the victory of the Americans at Saratoga convinced King Louis,
the 16th that the Americans could stand up as a fighting force and entered into
a formal Alliance with the Americans. By the end of 1777,
they promised troops money supplies, and most importantly,
and Naval fleet something. The American sorely lacked Horacio Gates. Meanwhile,
took much credit for the victory,
despite not having much to do with the actual battle strategy itself.
And he used it to advocate himself to replace Washington as general in chief and
attempt this ultimately failed.
[Inaudible].
Washington's army made winter camp at Valley forge North of Philadelphia.
That Windsor was brutal.
Busily cold and snowy ends around 2,500 American soldiers died at the
encampment.
The American cause was greatly helped by the presence of two foreign officers
who wanted to help the American cause the Marquis de Lafayette. So 19 year old,
French nobleman and soldier sailed for America in late 1777 against the orders
of his King and was made a general by Washington laughing.
It's brought knowledge of European warfare to the Americans,
and he had a positive effect on morale.
It is believed that the eventual Alliance between France and the Americans was
jus in no small parts to his efforts. Meanwhile, Baron Friedrich Von Steuben,
former Prussian army officer and administrator left Germany after being accused
of having homosexual affairs. He arrived at Valley forge in February,
1778 and was made inspector general of the army.
He was influential in developing a training program that turns the continental
army into a professional fighting force. He was a colorful figure,
elaborately dressed and prone to cursing at the soldiers in several languages
facing fallout from the campaign of 1777 general Howe resigned and was replaced
by sir Henry Clinton, Vinson abandons, Philadelphia,
and marched back to New York, pursued by Washington.
The two armies fought an indecisive battle at Monmouth on June the 28th and came
back to New York to discover a French fleet in New York Harbor.
The French had declared war on great Britain and what's it been a regional civil
conflict was now a continent spanning war involving several major European
powers.
The British government now were sending few reinforcements to their armies in
America, more concerned with protecting their Caribbean possessions.
The focus of the war now moved to the Southern colonies after the British
captured the city of Charleston, South Carolina in early 17,
80 and army commanded by Nord Wallace routed Horatio Gates at the battle of
Camden, which ended Gates his military career.
He was replaced by general Nathaniel green,
who engaged in hit and run tactics with Cornwallis.
His army that slowed their advanced North to Virginia Washington whose ranks
were now swelled by French soldiers and a French Naval fleet received word that
Cornell has moved his army to Yorktown sensing an opportunity to trap him that
Washington moved his army away from York to Virginia.
Cornwallis found himself surrounded.
He wasn't able to retreat by sea because the French fleet had blockaded it.
And Washington's troops lead siege to his fortifications.
After two weeks of battle, I want us to realize the situation was hopeless.
He surrendered to the allied army on October the 19th 1781.
The war was for all intents and purposes over the defeat of Yorktown caused the
collapse of Lord North's government in London and the new government called fee
storks in September, 1783,
the treaty of Paris was signed in which great Britain recognized the United
States of America as an independent nation.
The last British troops left New York at the end of 1783 against all the odds
and the hardships George Washington,
and the continental army had won the war and earned America. Independence
Was a national hero.
Now there were many in Congress who were prepared to offer him the title of
King, but Washington refused.
He was the head of the army and could have easily taken power.
How do you want to do, but Washington, wasn't interested in being a dictator.
So in December of 1783,
he voluntarily resigned his commissioners general in chief and returned to Mount
Vernon. The articles of Confederation,
which governs the new nation quickly proved to be inadequate.
And it became clear this a national constitution was needed to establish a
government for the United States.
Washington was called out of retirement to serve as president of the
constitutional convention of 1787 in Philadelphia, that,
and he oversaw the creation of a document that still forms the basis of American
law more than 200 years later,
and serves as the basis for national constitutions all over the world.
The first election for president of the United States was held in 1788 and
Washington was elected to serve as the first president.
He was inaugurated in New York city in April 17, 89.
Being the firm's president Washington was left to define many of the precedents
that still serve the executive branch today.
He settled on being addressed as Mr. President turning down the more elaborate
title, his excellent CC or his Highness,
he gave the first inaugural address and the first presidential address to the
assembled houses of Congress.
He also forms the executive branch into a cabinet of department secretaries,
which still persists to this day.
Most of Washington's time as president was spent playing referee to two warring
factions within his cabinets.
Washington was the only president not to be a member of a political party.
And didn't like the idea of them in the first place.
The same could not be said of Alexander Hamilton,
the secretary of the treasury and Thomas Jefferson,
secretary of state Hamilton believed that the future of the nation was in strong
federal government's national banking system and commerce in cities and forms
the Federalist party while Jefferson favor decentralized governments controlled
by the state since and economy controlled by agrarian interests.
And he hated the idea of banks. He forms the Jeffersonian Republican party.
The two were bits of rivals and cabinet meetings often degenerated into shouting
matches with Washington and having to step in to maintain order in favor to
Hamilton's plan and spent most of his first term on economic issues.
He was exhausted by 1792 and showed no interest in running for a second term,
but was begged to do so by all sides and was unanimously reelected by
1796, the outright refuse to run for a third term and chose to retire. This set.
Another president,
no president would serve more than two times until Franklin Roosevelt in 1940
and after Roosevelt died in office during his fourth term,
Congress passed an amendment to the constitution that set the two term limits
and to federal.
[Inaudible].
And again, returned to Mount Vernon.
Vice-president John Adams being elected in 1796 as a second president during
this time relations with France deteriorated after the French revolution.
And it seems like there might be war Washington accepted the position of
commander in chief of the United States army in 1798 to defend the country if it
was attacked, but no army would appear.
And Washington didn't have a field command on December the 13th, 1799.
Washington started suffering from a sore throat. The next day it was even worse.
Doctors were summons,
but disagreed on what was causing the illness and what to do about it.
At one point, nearly a pint of blood was drawn from him, blood blessing,
being a common medical practice at the time though,
it probably just made things worse at around 10:30 PM. On December the 14th,
George Washington died age 67 news of his death touched off a wave of national
morning that his funeral on December the 18th general,
Henry Lee known as the light horse Harry gave the eulogy in an ironic twist of
fate Lee's son.
Robert Eley would be the leading figure in a rebellion against the nation that
George Washington played a key role in founding Washington owns over 300 slaves
at the time of his death.
Slavery was essential to the building of his family's wealth,
but as he grew older,
Washington grew more uneasy with the institution of slavery. By the 1780s,
Washington was privately in favor of emancipation. He kept signs on the map.
So while presidents recognizing that it played such an oversized role in the
economy of the Southern States,
since that it could destroy the new nation Washington than the other founding
fathers, his failure to settle the question of slavery would lead to civil war.
60 years after Washington staff,
Washington wanted to free his own slaves while he was still alive,
but he wasn't able to persuade the other as of the Curtis,
a state to free their slaves. At the same time,
the slaves that worked at Mount Vernon had intermarried and started families and
Washington said he did not want to break up those families by freeing some and
not the rest.
Meaning the ones not freed could still be sold to someone else and shipped away
in his will be ordered that harvest slaves be freed immediately after his death,
but the rest being freed off his death,
Moffitt preempted this by freeing all of his slaves and January, 1801,
but never freed her own slaves,
thus causing the breakup of slave families that Washington had tried to prevent.
She died in May, 1802 at the age of eight, Georgia.
Martha Washington were entered at a tomb at Mount Vernon where they still are
today.
Despite some attempts by the American government to have the move to a tomb in
Washington, DC.
The new Capitol that was named after the nation's first president,
after his death memorials and monuments to Washington,
went up all over the country in the Capitol as the final 155 foot tall
Washington monuments was completed in 1888 because of a federal law passed in
1910 to limit the height of buildings in Washington, DC.
The monument is the tallest building in the city and is likely to remain that
way in the future.
The myth of Washington outgrew the man Washington was very quickly a character
emerged. That was almost God-like the person every American aspires to be.
But we think that his story is interesting enough on its own,
that it doesn't need to be embellished like that. Washington,
the man was a far more complicated figure than Washington, the myths,
but that just makes him more compelling as a historical figure.
Perhaps lighthouse Henry Lee said it best in his eulogy of Washington when he
described him as first in war,
first in peace and first in the hearts of his countrymen.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to subscribe and as always, thank you for watching.
[Inaudible].